the first inkling I had that I was
possibly could be connected to this
movie at all was that I got a call from
Alan and Howard I didn't know them but
they called came through the editor and
they said they told me why they were
calling me they said we have an idea
Disney is going to make a movie of this
lovely story this very story and there's
a part of a little woman mrs. Potts I
said mrs. Parker but oh yeah
oh she's a teapot I said well glad you
clarified that and we wondered if you
would be interested we like to play you
our recording of the song that you would
sing as mrs. potts so I listened to it
and it was a it was tale as old as time
yes but they sang it kind of rock style
at that time there's all this time you
know and I thought copy you know teapot
singing that stuff well if if you'll
just let me have it let is send me the
music let me record my what I think
might be a more realistic version of a
teapot singing Oh
so they said well you have more
experience with teapots Oh a lot of
experience I've got the biggest
collection of teapots you'll ever see
during the period when the movie was
coming out everybody sent me a teapot
need i say more
and of course there was some lovely ones
with frilly hats and everything for the
tops and there are all around the place
anyway
III really took it very seriously I
thought oh how exciting to be in a great
Disney movie like this and this is a
wonderful story so I did my version of
what I felt it should be and I'm happy
to say that they grabbed it a hot nail
and sinker and that was it that my
version became the version I had a lot
of fun putting the lady together because
I had known a little woman who was had
been a cook when I was a little girl and
her name was Beattie and she was a
Beatrice was her name but she had this
wonderful kind of warm axe and a way of
talking you know like this a real
company and I I just absorbed all those
sounds when I was a kid and I've used
them all throughout my career one way or
another and I thought its Beattie
that's who I'm going to go for and I had
a wonderful time putting together and of
course it was written so magnificently
by the writers and and of course the
animation was so extraordinary and
wonderful but it all works thank God it
all came together melded together and
mrs. Potts became one of the most
important characters that I ever
portrayed in motion pictures
I think she's been a little shy here Dom
would you tell the rest of the story of
her recording session and the producer I
think you probably remember very well
yeah I remember you flying out with your
dear husband to New York where we
recorded this song and your flight was
delayed and had to land in Las Vegas
because there was a bomb skier on the
plane that's right and you had to change
planes and I found out about nice oh
that's fine we'll move off till tomorrow
and I got word from you that was like no
no I'll be there
and just hold the orchestra so we waited
we held the orchestra and you had landed
and then you said yes I'll still come in
I say you don't have to come in we'll do
it tomorrow it'll be fine I'm still
coming elevator doors open you came in
the orchestra was still there we tuned
you stepped into the booth and sang the
song and that's the song it's in the
movie so thank you for remembering that
it's impressive
I was so odd to to sing with the New
York Philharmonic I nearly died
I had to get it right yes yeah and you
did yeah in a sense I think your
character is kind of the maternal sense
of the sensibility of the picture oh yes
yes she's in love with laughs and and
and watching these two is just she's
absolutely loved being part of it and
she's going to you know she's going to
bend in I'm just going to help them
they're gonna be the person is going to
get them together you know and this is a
mad about the idea and of course it
succeeds Oh